Une vidéo c'est bien, mais en 3D, c'est mieux !
Ouah je suis en 3D, je rentre dans ton ecran !
C'est bon, ça va.
Pendant les trois quarts de l'année je pense que il y a une seule chose, l'été
C'est génial avec les vacances, le soleil, tout ça. Mais j'omets toujours un petit détail:
Tout les été j'ai envie d'aménager dans mon frigo tellement que j'ai chaud !
Attention, je ne parle pas de n'importe quelle chaleur, d'ailleurs tu peux établir différents niveaux de chaleur en fonction de ta façon de dormir.
Bon bah d'abord tu as le niveau 0, normal...
ensuite tu as le niveau 1...
puis le niveau 2...
et moi je te parle du niveau 24 !
*sanglots de désespoir*
Je déteste cette chaleur, j'ai juste envie de m'enlever la peau, mais c'est pas possible alors pour palier à ça,
je fais un truc pas du tout cautionné par les écologistes: je prends des douches tout le temps.
Mais quand je dis tout le temps, c'est genre... tout le temps, quoi.
Ne fait pas semblant, tu fais pareil!
Ah, ça fait du bien !
Il fait chaud quand même!
Je prendrais bien une petite douche ! Allez !
D'ailleurs je prends tellement de douches que je pourrais prendre une douche en continu, en fait.
Tu peux me passer l'eau, s'il te plait?
Merci.
Oh...oh non, je m'en suis foutu partout!
Baaah!
Oui, parce que quand je ne prends pas de douche, ou quand je n'ai pas la tête dans le congélo, je bois de l'eau.
Ma tante, euh, elle a, euh, un chat, euh, mon autre tante elle a un perroquet d'occasion...
Ah non... non,non... non pardon! Je BOIS de L'EAU!
Ma cousine elle a, euh, un bocal avec plein de poissons, euh, asiatiques.
Et sinon j'ai une nièce qui a un bonsai, mais euh...
Tu veux une paille?
Tout est bon pour avoir moins chaud, hein.
Un truc qui rafraîchit bien, c'est de mettre du déo. Tu sais, dès que t'en met sous les bras...
Aaaaaaaaaaaah!
Par contre je ne comprends pas le délire de ceux qui font les pubs pour les déos.
Avec le mec qui met du déo au ralenti.
Qui, sur terre, sent mauvais... d'ici?
Pourquoi il se met du déo sur le bide, c'est pas normal. Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a déjà dit...
Houla... houla ça pue le ventre ici, houlala, c'est toi qui sent du ventre?
Ah, mets du déo sur le bide.
NON!
Alors, pourquoi?!
En tout cas, avec tous les étés que j'ai passé à craindre la chaleur, j'ai bien compris un truc:
plus jamais... je ne rentre dans une voiture garée au soleil.
Il y a les sièges qui te brûlent, il y a le volant qui te brûle. C'est un calvaire et tu peux pas faire autrement.
On devrait s'en servir comme instrument de torture, voilà... ou pour autre chose en fait:
Elle a toujours été passionnée par tout ce qui est jeux de société, euh, jeu de dame...
*DING*
Ah, excuse-moi.
*Musique d'opéra*
Huuuuum! Excellent.
Ah j'ai une idée, combattons la canicule en partageant ma vidéo sur Facebook et en rejoignant ma page aussi.
Même si tu sens mauvais du ventre... ah je m'en fous, ah oui...
Puis aller sur Cyprien.fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos.
Un jour de chaleur... ou pas, hein, même une nuit de chaleur, un jour de pas chaleur...